on the one hand they want to claim that  sex is innate gender is innate we're  born with it we're born knowing who we  are and by the way if you're born a man  but you really feel on some deep  metaphysical level that you are a woman  then you really are a woman on some  level and you are so much a woman and it  is so important to uh to be able to  express your innate essential gendered  self that it is encouraged for you to  spend 15 20 50 000 on surgery to  mutilate yourself to appear more like  the other gender that's what they tell  us on one hand on the other hand they  tell us men and women are exactly the  same and there's no difference at all  those two things cannot simultaneously  be true you have to pick one the left  can either have feminism or the left can  have transgenderism but they can't be  the same if men and women are exactly  the same then why would I spend fifty  thousand dollars to have many surgeries  done to emulate one gender or the other  doesn't make sense